Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute Papers
with Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
Everyone who watches this series knows that
among many other scientific topics, I am severely
addicted to fluid simulations, and today,
it's time to relapse!
And this time, we're going to run wind tunnel
tests on hummingbirds.
Typically, when a new engine, airplane, or
even a new phone is being designed, we're
interested in knowing how the heat flow and
dissipation will look like, preferably before
we're designing an object.
To do so, we often run some virtual wind tunnel
tests and optimize our design until we're
happy with the results.
Then, we can proceed to build these new contraptions.
Simulating the pressure distribution and aerodynamic
forces is a large topic, however, visualizing
these results is at least as well-studied
and difficult as writing a simulator.
What is it exactly that we're interested in?
Even if we have an intuitive particle-based
simulation, millions and millions of particles,
it is clearly impossible to show the path
for every one of them.
Grid-based simulations are often even more
challenging to visualize well.
So how do we choose what to visualize and
what not to show on the screen?
And in this paper, we can witness a new way
of visualizing velocity and vorticity fields.
And this visualization happens through Clebsch-maps.
This is a mathematical transformation where
we create a sphere, and a set of points on
this sphere correspond to vortex lines and
their evolution over time.
However, if instead of only points, we pick
an entire region on this sphere, as you can
see the north and south pole regions here,
we obtain vortex tubes.
These vortex tubes provide an accurate representation
of the vorticity information within the simulation,
and this is one of the rare cases where the
validity of such a solution can also be shown.
Such a crazy idea, loving it!
And with this, we can get a better understanding
of the air flow around the wings of a hummingbird,
but we can also learn more from pre-existing
NASA aircraft datasets.
Have a look at these incredible results.
Publishing a paper at the SIGGRAPH conference
is an incredible feat that typically takes
a few brilliant guys and several years of
unbelievably hard work.
Well, apparently this is not such a challenge
for Albert Chern, who was also the first author
of this and the Schrödinger's Smoke paper
just a year ago that we reported on.
He is doing incredible work at taking a piece
of mathematical theory and showing remarkable
applications of it in new areas where we would
think it doesn't belong at all.
The link is available in the video description,
for both this and the previous works, make
sure to have a look.
There is lots of beautifully written mathematics
to be read there that seems to be from another
world.
It's a truly unique experience.
The paper reports that the source code is
also available, but I was unable to find it
yet.
If you have found a public implementation,
please let me know and I'll update the video
description with your link.
Thanks for watching and for your generous
support, and I'll see you next time.